and
i recall
in the days and the weeks preceding the
election there were various people i
would encounter during my one trip per
week out of the house where i would go
to the grocery store
and a lot of people were under the
impression that after the election ended
covet 19 would go away well
it hasn't now i guess they would say the
election still hasn't ended but it's
still not going to go away once the last
vote is counted i hope people realize
that the numbers are going up nationwide
as everyone who was taking this
seriously expected from the moment we
realized cold and flu season will put
people indoors and enhance the chances
for
spreading the virus
nfl teams are seeing a spike in players
testing positive away from the facility
for as long chris is there is
anything other than a home market bubble
and everyone goes their separate ways at
the end of practice at the end of
meetings after a game you're going to
have these opportunities for people to
test positive and they are jacob martin
texans linebacker
overnight the news came out that he
tested positive that was on a wednesday
morning sample right the pcr result came
in overnight texans are going to work
remotely today yeah they're missing a
day of practice in advance of a game
against the jaguars and that's just
going to be part of the background noise
for the nfl and we just hope it stays in
the background so they can play the
games but that's just going to be part
of this churn for the rest of the season
chris yeah it is you're right i mean
well there's just nothing we can do
right now as you see
anywhere whether you watch the news or
just at least living in your community
yeah the spread is real i mean it
certainly has spread more here in the
new york connecticut area it's
infiltrated by kids schools in certain
areas and schools around town so
yeah this is something we're going to
have to continue to deal with and of
course you know sports yeah it's it's
different but it's still a reflection on
society and you got you know 100 guys
walking into a building every day yeah
well with the state of the country and
covid right now some of them are going
to walk in with covet and we'll see what
where we go but you know it's of course
it hurts football teams i mean now man
hey look at the matchup tonight the
49ers yet not are only injured but now
they've lost a little battle with
culvert this week to where they're
banged up beat up football team as bad
as i can ever remember any top-notch
team being banged up and now they're
going to miss two
other big-time football players because
they're on the coveted list so
teams are going to be handicapped in
certain weeks no practice missing
players and that's just the way it's
going to be here until like you said
until it goes to the bubble or something
like that and then we won't have to have
these conversations nearly as much
and let's boil this down as it relates
to the san francisco 49ers what happened
was kendrick bourne 49ers receiver
tested positive
yesterday we found out about it and i
want to be as accurate as i can about
how this process works it would have
been a tuesday morning sample
with the result returned into wednesday
morning informing the 49ers that bourne
had tested positive well tuesday was a
work day this week because of a thursday
night game so what they immediately
start doing
is contact tracing
assessing which other players or coaches
fall into that high risk category for
potentially developing it this is the
nfl's way of dealing with the incubation
period that's one of the big donut holes
we talked about earlier in the season
and the nfl just dealt with it at some
point in the past few weeks chris with
enhanced protocols i think it was early
october
that's when the nfl said okay here's
what we're going to do
when a guy tests positive we're going to
identify these high-risk close contacts
and we're
preemptively taking them out of
circulation for five days yeah even if
they never get it
so that's how the 49ers are getting
screwed tonight not that they're getting
screwed because this can potentially
happen to anyone but born test positive
three other guys were deemed to be close
contacts demo samuel who was going to
miss the game anyway with a hamstring
injury trent williams starting left
tackle hello
he's not available tonight even if he
never gets covered 19
and then
receiver brandon nyuk first round draft
pick guy they traded up to get guy who
has shown some flashes of high level
ability he's not available tonight
either not because he's injured but
because he had too close of contact with
kendrick bourne in that window after he
gave a positive sample yeah that
ultimately was determined
to
indeed be positive because 19. and look
at all the other guys they're missing
tonight
i mean this is unbelievable you can
almost have an all-star team of their
best players that aren't available
tonight
it's it's i don't remember ever a team
of you know super bowl quality ever
having to deal with this type of you
know injuries in a given year it truly
is unbelievable you know bad luck yeah
certainly whatever else it is i mean i i
don't know what to say about it but mike
let me just get this straight if it was
a normal sunday game right
iuk and trenton williams would probably
be able to play because it's still
within that is it it's close right or
maybe not yeah it's close it's very
close and we're dealing with that with
matthew stafford the lions quarterback
who's on the covet 19 reserve list
because he was exposed to someone away
from the facility his wife announced
last night that the family was exposed
stafford was
candid about it when i don't know how
else the lions would have known about it
and boom right you're on the cove at 19
reserve list and and look this is
something that we've been talking about
for weeks now do you really think these
people are going to be i'm surprised
stafford was he did the right thing yeah
because he could have developed it and
given to someone else and maybe it ends
up being caught by someone that it kills
so it is the right thing to do it's the
mature thing to do we were praising otto
beckham jr for that a couple of weeks
ago for saying hey i don't feel well you
know in any other year guys just suck it
up and keep going but because of the
possibility at cova 19 he raised his
hand and he was sent home for a few days
so stafford's able to come back for the
game sunday but not practice at all this
week i think it would have been close
as to whether or not the 49ers players
could have been back for a sunday game
right because it was a tuesday exposure
and i it's five days i think though from
when you're placed on the list they were
placed on the list yesterday only
because it took a day to figure out who
was in close contact and the other thing
i'd like to know right
was the close contact inevitable because
of being on the practice field or was it
negligent from being in the building and
getting too close
because there's the nfl's
belief here is yeah right that if
everyone follows the procedures
even if a guy walks in the door positive
and we find out later he gave a sample
that was tested positive no one else
should be at risk well clearly three
other guys
based on being around kendrick born on
tuesday we're at risk so that's where
i'm confused and there's a whole lot of
transparency no see there's a lot of
confusion and people are just like what
the hell is going on and it feels
arbitrary and if i was a 49ers fan i'd
be pissed right now chris that the game
is going forward move it to monday we've
already shown that we can stretch that
rubber band move it around give us a
fair chance here move it to monday move
it to tuesday if you have to give us a
chance to play this game otherwise
tonight it's a joke it's meaningless
it's the a team for the packers versus
the b team for the 49ers yeah i mean
you're right i mean in a lot of ways
they have a lot more ground to stand on
than like let's say the las vegas
raiders a few weeks ago with all the
offensive linemen right that was an
issue you know we had heard there was
you know some rumblings out of the
raiders organization about they didn't
think it was fair that they were going
to be have be forced to play on sunday
that sunday against the tampa bay
buccaneers i mean
all the injuries
covered guys on on that list now
you know a team that's playing one of
the most important games of the year i
mean this is they're getting towards
like well we can only lose maybe one or
two more games the rest of the year and
we got to make a run but even on that
mike you know with all the injuries all
those replacement guys and
whoever the hell's playing at
quarterback tonight for the 49ers all
that they don't get to do again any
walk-throughs nothing to like really
help their football team or get a feel
or a grasp of hey you're playing here
you got to think about this and you know
this is our game plan and you'll get to
walk through it a little bit i mean that
to me i just
wow they're as handicapped as any team
i've seen this year being forced to play
a football game i mean yeah i mean this
short a period of time the injuries and
then of course the covet stuff i
understand them i mean i understand your
point you know i i guess the nfl is kind
of just trying to say what no you have
enough guys to field this we're not
going to play these type of games
anymore and move the schedule around
because they are losing a little
flexibility as we go forward and i guess
they're just kind of finally you know
playing playing hardball here i don't
know mike what's your take on that
well as we entered the league there was
that or the season excuse me there was
that sense of next man up and there's 16
guys on the practice squad who can be
elevated up to 90 minutes before kickoff
no questions asked and i think we all
believe that it would be a situation
where
on a sunday morning
five guys wake up sick
or they find out that five guys tested
positive and they automatically have to
replace guys who actually are positive
for the virus with other players and the
sense was that under those circumstances
the nfl would say hey too bad you're
down five offensive linemen
next man up you don't have enough guys
on the practice squad to fill those
spots that's on you for not making good
roster decisions
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports